e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monaco avait l'air renfrogné au départ
du grand prix monte carl pas au rayon de
soleil en effet et même quelques gouttes
depuis qu'au moment où les seize bolide
silence dans les rues de la cité c'est
ce bolide qui s'emballe et 300 chevaux
qui s'emballe son capot d'une voiture de
course cela fait du bruit et cela compte
aussi parfois des accidents résultat
trois voitures hors course dans celle de
maurice trintignant elles n'ont pas
parcouru plus de 200 m les autres
pilotes de s'en soucie guère le plus
d'années g il mène la rente suivi du néo
zélandais mc laren et de l'américain
filer et pendant 92 tours sur les 100
tours que comportent les preuves grammy
avec la virtuosité tranquille du pilote
sûr de son affaire continue de tourner
seul en tête à plus de 110 de moyens et
d'ars à 25 kilomètres du but sa boîte de
vitesses a rendu l'âme et c'est la
numéro 14 de mclaren l'atlantiste qui va
franchir en tête la ligne d'arrivée
aspirant dans son sillage la ferrari de
ville ive
[Applaudissements]
fini les chevaux de bois de nos
grands-mères en californie la classe
biberon préfère les émotions fortes
chaque année il en est ainsi dans la
petite ville de salinas
en pratique le rodéo comme des grands
parfois avec la maîtrise des vrais cow
boys comme dans les westerns
des bûches il y en aura pour tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et l'on se réjouit du malheur des autres
cet âge est décidément sans pitié le
taureau également et en californie on
est pour l'égalité des sexes les filles
en piste comme les garçons c'est
évidemment moins paisible et un concours
de beauté
le château de champs a prêté son cadre
au quatrième week-end franco-britannique
qui grâce au premier soleil de juin ne
s'est pas cantonnée au coin du feu
cordiales et franches tel fut
l'atmosphère dans laquelle le général de
gaulle et monsieur macmillan ont étudié
le problème numéro un la participation
de l'angleterre à l'europe des six
triomphateur du cosmos scott carpenter
frais et dispos comme le départ a
retrouvé à son retour de l'île du grand
kirk sa femme sa mère et ses quatre
enfants avec une joie tendre que laisse
bien deviné ces images personne bien sûr
n'avait suivi son voyage avec autant de
ferveur autant d'impatience et bien
entendu tout le monde est allé regarder
la capsule à l'intérieur de laquelle ce
grand garçon avait passé près de cinq
heures pendant ces trois tours de terre
à manipuler les manettes et les boutons
de son mystérieux tableau de bord de cet
immense succès de cette grande aventure
voici le témoin absolue cette petite
cage étroite qui est allé pour les as
à jérusalem adolf eichmann condamné à
mort pour l'extermination de six
millions de juifs a pris place une
nouvelle fois dans la cage de verre du
palais de justice de jérusalem la
dernière c'était en effet pour entendre
prononcé le rejet de son appel par le
juge silberg au nom de la cour suprême
israélienne
[Musique]
ni
l'europe où
rien ne souffrait plus ashman désormais
deux jours plus tard la grâce lui était
refusée et la peine immédiatement
appliquées c'était pour la potence cas
eichmann quitté sa cage de verre le
bourg on a payé si l'on peut jamais payé
pour pareil crime
[Musique]
et les bris calcinés c'est tout ce qui
reste du boeing 707 qui devait ramener
de paris atlanta 123 touristes
américains avec huit membres de
l'équipage ont péri seul rescapé deux
hôtesses éjecté de la carlingue ont
miraculeusement survécu
n'ayant pu décoller le mastodonte est
venu s'écraser après une course folle de
300 mètres au delà de la piste d'orly
entre deux pavillons de villeneuve le
roi et c'est une chance qu'on n'ait pas
aujourd'hui à déplorer d'autres victimes
parmi les habitants une des plus grandes
catastrophes aériennes
[Musique]
au cours de valdahon près de besançon
trois mille officiers parmi lesquels des
officiers allemands au découvert les
grandes manoeuvres de l'armée futur
c'est exceptionnel manoeuvre interarmes
et usages en effet des derniers modèles
de matériel et en particulier des chars
équipés d'engins
l'idée de conception française un
épisode de la guerre presse bouton
si buffon a pu dire un jour le cheval la
plus noble conquête de l'homme c'est que
cette affirmation s'étaient traduites
dans la réalité des les âges les plus
reculées le cheval fut en effet de tout
temps et les à l'idée de combat de
victoire de succès
et dans un domaine plus terre à terre
l'enfant at il jamais réclamé plus
ardemment un autre compagnon qu'un
cheval
de là le succès à travers les
générations des chevaux de bois de nos
jardins publics et des orchestrion dont
le tournoiement régulier a bercé toutes
les enfances
de là aussi le succès des chevaux à
jupon comme un nombre de traditions
folkloriques de nos provinces
et là on n'a pas cesser de perpétrer ces
jeux de chevaux porteurs de chance c'est
peut-être de cette mystique cheval égale
chance que s'inspire cette année le
grand prix de paris or de l'attrait
qu'elles apportent aux turfistes cette
course déterminera en effet au
sweepstake de la loterie nationale
l'affectation des plus gros lot 100
millions 200 millions et encore plus de
30 noeuds de 5 à 50 millions de quoi
rêver
[Musique]
en ce mois de mai dans le décor
renaissance de la cour du belvédère au
vatican on pourrait presque se croire
revenu au xvième siècle dans le costume
que dessina pour eux michel-ange les
nouvelles recrues de la garde suisse ont
prêté serment comme ils l'ont fait
depuis la création de leur corps voici
plus de quatre siècles et demi
la main gauche sur la hampe du drapeau
les trois doigts de la main droite levée
en signe de dévotion à la sainte trinité
chaque nouvelle enrôler a juré fidélité
au souverain pontife
rien n'a changé depuis jules 2 mais
alors la garde suisse comptait 200
hommes elle n'en compte plus que la
moitié depuis le pape léon xiii
[Musique]
ans
du balcon sa sainteté jean xxiii a salué
comme ses prédécesseurs ces soldats d'un
autre âge dont la présence dans leurs
aspects inchangé perpétue une tradition
et exalte un souvenir le souvenir des
147 gardes suisses qui tombèrent dans 15
127 en défendant la ville éternelle
contre les lansquenets du connétable de
bourbon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]